hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Korra episode 5 video kuvira
turned a big corner and Korra is back in
action it's just the eye of the storm
Korra went through hell to fix herself
now it's like that really pregnant pause
before everything goes insane again
quick reminder to new round of the
giveaway starts right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so careful
for spoilers if you're not caught up on
Korra I need to get my own version of
Zulia so I could say Zhu Li do the top 5
thing but here we go number 5 Farrukh
superweapon
totally not surprised it turned out to
be a weapon of mass destruction Farrukh
speechifying reminded me of the original
manhattan project you know the atomic
bomb project especially the way he was
filming himself chronicling his progress
you can think of it as like a wink back
to the movers from book 2 you know we
got all the nuktuk stuff in book 3 so
maybe when they're all done with
everything Bolin can retire and start
making movers again with Varrick that
animation effects on it look just like
the energy blast from Koren una vaatu
during that book 2 finale it's like he's
accidentally replicated energy bending I
mean energy bending is way more
complicated than just blasting people
from your chest but you get the idea
like they're replicating powers that
only the Avatar used to have
just because kuvira is gonna have the
destructive power of an avatar I'm not
gonna think of her as the dark avatar
but someone feel free to run with that
on tumblr I would pay good money to see
that cosplay at the end of the season I
do think that they're gonna find a way
to turn those batteries into clean
energy it's like the idea of cold fusion
in real life in modern day like it's
free energy for everyone who else is
proud of bark for trying to put the
brakes on that I think we knew how it
was gonna go down the minute it blew up
who here is gonna do something really
really bad with it number 4
Zhu Li turns a big corner corner kuvira
two biggest characters in the episode
but Zhu Li was the biggest badass and
yes I know everyone is wondering what's
up with her turning sides at the end I
think that's all bullcrap she's already
shown herself to be smarter and a better
fighter than barik so it stands the
reason she's also a better manipulator I
think she just said all that stuff so
she could stay and protect Farrukh I'm
hoping they have a little bit of fun
with it though like they make her
character pretend to be bad for another
episode or two she also got the best
line in the episode they let her spit
vorak slime back in his face guards do
the thing
Sheen warka this really weird
relationship it seems a little bit toxic
but I guess it works for them I totally
think they're gonna seal the deal before
the end of the season number three
soohyun's flashback always loved
flashbacks on avatar but in this case I
think we already had a pretty good idea
what went down between her and kuvira
they had that scene back in Republic
City where kuvira called her out for
sitting on her butt when the earth
Kingdom was in chaos I actually thought
it was a lot more interesting that they
explained what's been going on with
Betar jr. being so crazy hating on his
family he was nuts in this episode even
kuvira told him to chill she says she
did not brainwash him which of course
means she totally brainwashed the crap
out of him not in the sense that the Dai
Li would brainwash someone she just
whispered in his ear
number two cuvee reports Bolin all of
the metal kool-aid but of course :
figures out what's going on takes him a
moment but he figures it out I don't
think this surprised anyone there's no
way we're gonna go into the back half of
the season with team Korra split up I
know MA CO and Asami are still in
Republic City but we still have a couple
more weeks before we past the halfway
mark I'm surprised they didn't do more
with the Bolin character during the
negotiation I figured he was gonna go on
his own first it seemed like the minute
kuvira walked through the door soohyun
already made her bind up so it was kind
of pointless having Bolin there he had
that big speech but it didn't look like
anyone was listening to him mech battle
totally amazing always loved fighting
mix the trailer totally didn't do it
justice Zhu Li has totally been holding
out on us she isn't a bender so I can't
see her like an Asami character really
smart really good fighter so of course
she can pilot that mech if you didn't
catch it break explain during Comic Con
that the mechs look different based on
the rank they have like military ranks
so I think the green ones are of higher
rank we did learn some really important
stuff though lava bending very effective
against mechs the minute Bolin lava
bended they went down instantly so just
remember that it's like Mach o lightning
bending being wat the end of book three
just instant takedown then there's the
re-education this is actually a little
bit funny don't you feel like the Dai Li
would be the camp counselors there when
kuvira said she was sending Zhu Li there
I also kind of thought of Judy and my
number one WTF moment of course korra
kuvira classic gunslinger moment korra
totally gave her a chance now it's time
to kick some butt after she saves suyun
and her sons
I don't think there's any way that
midnight raid is gonna go well it
sounded like soo Ian took her sons to go
capture kuvira i don't think they were
gonna try and kill her
but either way potentially very bad PR
move kuvira is actually playing it
pretty smart she even said the world's
eyes are on us so soohyun attacking is
gonna be all she needs to launch a
full-scale assault
I love how sue yen also kind of treated
Korra like a Zhu lis character Korra do
the thing do the avatar thing
theoretically Korra would be able to
Earthbend a giant hand just what all the
mechs like flies but she and kuvira had
such a classic gunslinger standoff I
feel like it would be a huge bummer if
they didn't at least have some sort of
face off against each other
Korra is gonna have to learn how to be a
politician I feel like she needs to
learn how to play the game of Thrones
she's defined Cersei Lannister it didn't
really fit into my top moments but Asami
with her father was a huge deal the
actor that plays Hiroshi Sato actually
said he was coming back to do scenes a
long time ago so we knew who's gonna be
here we just didn't know what he was
gonna be doing it seems like based on
what's going on between pitar jr. and
his father Asami scenes were all about
healing family relationships and
forgiveness and that's gonna be a big
through-line for the characters of this
season forgiveness so just remember that
whenever it comes time for the final
battle in the last couple of episodes
Korra is gonna have to learn how to
forgive kuvira and they'll have to play
some pie show maybe cry a little too
because it'll be the last couple of
episodes of Korra
let me know what was your favorite
moment from the episode and do you think
that everyone's gonna be able to forgive
kuvira after she does something
completely crazy with that super weapon
I feel like that's the tease she's gonna
do something awful with it if there's
anything that would cause the world to
turn against her it would be some big
disaster without weapon you don't place
a gun on a table before fight if you
don't plan on using it if any of you are
theater geeks there's this thing called
Chekhov's gun he had this famous quote
where he said one must never place a
rifle on the stage if it's not going to
go off so just plan on that giant spirit
vine rifle going off which is actually a
good transition to my review I gave it a
solid eight just because it was such a
huge turning point for all the
characters even some of the minor
characters I'm always amazed at how much
time bright devotes to the lesser
characters it really makes the Avatar
universe just feel that much deeper that
being said Zhu Li just got so much more
interesting pitar junior is like the
whiny son with no self-esteem so yes
it is annoying to listen to him complain
so much about how hard it was tough
growing up rich and famous I'm sure all
the poor people in Ba Sing se
really give a about that I feel
like if you're not gonna be a character
that people are gonna admire like you're
not gonna be like a Korra character you
might as well be someone everyone really
really hates that's why I think Bryke
wrote in to be so vicious during that
mech battle if you're gonna be bad be
very bad don't half-ass being evil
somewhere off in the distance I'm sure
Azula is laughing at all of them just in
general
totally not surprised when Korra
episodes of this good it's been amazing
in book four so far like each episode
has been better than the last but I do
still think that episode three the
big-top core episode is probably the
best so far mostly because it's
fanservice but I totally forgive it for
that so Q&A video for this posting
tomorrow so leave all your questions
I'll try and get it up early just
because the Doctor Who finale is
happening and sometimes they don't get
the core videos up quite fast enough so
look for that you can click here to
watch it I'll add the annotation as soon
as I post it and you can click here for
Korra episode 4 thank you so much for
watching so it's all high five and I'll
see you guys tonight